joining us now to talk about all of this
and also the spread of the new covid
sub-variant here in these United States
is Dr Ashish Shah the White House
coveted response coordinator Dr John
good morning thank you for being here
hey good morning thanks for having me
back
so we just heard in the Liz Palmer
report about China that we're not
getting reliable information about the
spread of covet in that country no
surprise there but how concerned are you
that we might get a big surprise in the
form of a more lethal or dangerous
variant from that country
yeah it's a very good question look
first and foremost our hearts go out to
the Chinese people who a lot of whom are
suffering right now because of the way
the virus is spreading in the country in
terms of openness and transparency this
is something we have believed very
strongly from the beginning China should
be forthcoming on the data and on the
issue of a new variant you know one of
the things that China is not doing is
sharing its genomic surveillance data
every other country does this is when
you take the virus and you sequence it
and then you make it publicly available
every other country is doing it China is
not that makes it very hard for the
scientific Community to spot new
variants really important for the
Chinese government to do that so we may
not even know the U.S has imposed
testing requirements for travelers
coming from China and that's raised
questions about xenophobia anti-asian
bias well it will contribute to that
putting that to one side there's also
the question of will it be effective how
effective do you think that will be in
preventing any variant that could be of
concern from coming in from China yeah
so first and foremost on the issue of
you know the policy itself it applies to
everybody whether you're an American
you're a Chinese person if you're coming
from China you need to get a test first
it's part of a comprehensive policy and
the comprehensive policy has testing
before you leave also has enhanced
genomic surveillance once people arrive
here this is our effort to make sure
that if there is a new variant we spot
it early and that we try to keep as many
infections out of the country as
possible I think the whole package
itself is going to be very effective
Dr Shaw how much will the latest booster
shot protect Americans from the new
variant spreading here it's a great
question the answer is substantially
better than any of our prior vaccines
and here's what we know based on all the
data we have the new bivalent vaccine
this is the new one that we updated in
September uh does seem to provide a good
degree of protection against infection
and terrific protection against serious
illness so this is why the number one
thing people can do against this new uh
xbv-15 again funny name but uh the
number one thing people can do is make
sure they go out and get that new
bivalent vaccine
Dr John how about the covet antiviral
jug paxlovid is that still good when it
comes to being effective up against this
subvariant absolutely I mean based on
again everything we know it's a new
sub-variant we're doing the tests but we
have every reason to believe that the
oral antiviral paxilvate again super
effective drug if you get sick you
should get evaluated for getting it
um everything we know about it suggests
that it's going to work just fine
against a new variant
all right Dr ashisha thank you so much